wir fragen uns in welchen Winter steuern
wir da eigentlich wie bitter wird der
Winter heute hat der Kanzler im
Bundestag gesagt für diesen Winter ist
Deutschlands Energie Sicherheit wohl
gewährleistet das wichtige Wörtchen
hierbei ist wohl Robert junglisch out
Experte das Wörtchen wohl wie sehr
beunruhigt sie das in diesem
Zusammenhang naja mich beunruhigt das
gar nicht mehr weil ich weiß
wahrscheinlich mehr über die
Versorgungssicherheit als der
Bundeskanzler das Problem ist einfach
die Politik versucht er die ganze Zeit
schon mit Nebelkerzen den wahren Zustand
zu verschleiern es kann ja wenn ein Herr
Habeck nach Katar fliegt und kommt
wieder und sagt er hat eine Vereinbarung
mit den Kataris getroffen und es gibt
gar keine oder wenn der Scholz nach
Saudi Arabien fliegt und sagt er kommt
mit LG wieder und dann ist es am Ende
ein Tanker wir brauchen 685
tankerladungen dann sind das alles
Nebelkerzen also ähm eigentlich ist das
Thema dramatisch und wenn ich mir
angucke wir haben eine
Fußballweltmeisterschaft wo Stadien
klimatisiert werden müssen und wir haben
hier nicht mehr genug Gas ab Februar
nächsten Jahres dann ist das hier eine
verrückte Welt eine verrückte Welt jetzt
wollen wir konkret werden wie
wahrscheinlich ist für sie der Blackout
und wie gut sind wir darauf vorbereitet
also fangen wir mit der
Wahrscheinlichkeit an ich denke in
diesem Winter ist der Blackout relativ
unwahrscheinlich was aber nichts an der
Gefahr des Blackouts ändert wenn er denn
Eintritt und das ist eigentlich der
entscheidende Punkt wir können den
Blackout nicht ausschließen und weil wir
nicht ausschließen können deswegen
müssen wir mit der Gefahr rechnen und
müssen uns auf die Gefahr vorbereiten
und da sind wir bei dem Problem die
Politik tut eben genau das nicht dass
sie die Bevölkerung so aufrüttelt so
sensibilisiert dass sie endlich hergeht
und die notwendigen Lebensmittel
einkauft die notwendigen Wasser
Medikamente und alles anschafft denn
dann wäre der Blackout von der
menschlichen Seite überhaupt kein
Problem aber weil immer gesagt wird auch
von unserem Bundeskanzler die
Stromversorgung ist sicher es wird
keinen Blackout geben hat im Sommer
Interview noch gesagt deswegen nehmen
die Leute die Gefahren nicht ernst und
das ist eine dramatisch große Gefahr und
wenn das eintreten würde gäbe es hier
einen Bürgerkrieg und in diesem Winter
wenn wenn alles gut geht wir haben ja
momentan alle Kraftwerke wieder
mobilisiert die es irgendwo gibt dann
werden wir genug Strom über den Winter
haben aber dann ist das Problem ja nicht
beseitigt sondern im Februar sind die
Gasspeicher leer und dann gibt es kein
russisches Gasspeicher mehr um die
wieder aufzufüllen und dann fängt die
Krise erst richtig an und ich meine es
geht ja noch weiter wir müssen ja nicht
nur auf die Energie gucken wir müssen ja
auch auf die Arbeitsplätze schauen denn
wenn der BASF nicht mehr genug Energie
bekommt dann waren dann die ab und dann
machen die das auch ganz schnell weil in
China zahlen die für die Kilowattstunde
3 € Cent an Strom und hier ist es eh
schon viel zu teuer und jetzt können Sie
alle gehen und weil sie sagen können ja
ihr könnt uns ja nicht mit Energie
beliefern und dann haben wir das Drama
jetzt wenn es ab dem 5 Dezember die das
Öl im Wagen noch gegen Russland gibt
dann kann Schwedt zu machen dann haben
wir ein Benzin ein dieselproblem und
auch weiter steigende Kosten und und die
Politik tut nichts und ich verstehe es
nicht
Ela Anna die Politik tut nicht das
klingt unfassbar dass er nicht irgendwo
in der Schublade wirkliche Pläne dafür
sind wenn so etwas in Deutschland
passiert
ja die Politik würde von sich heute
sagen und da hat sie ja zum Teil auch
gesagt dass sie sehr viel getan hat das
ganze
auf Blackout guckt dann bin ich das höre
dann denke ich auch oh Gott wo sind
meine Kerzen und wo ist mein Gaskocher
und das kann ich alles noch heute habe
ich so eine Anleitung gelesen wie man
sich selber noch eine Heizung mit zum
Topf bauen kann
genau also
geht relativ schnell aber trotzdem ich
meine ich will das gar nicht ins
lächerliche ziehen den ganzen Gegenteil
das ist ja offenbar ernst nehmen das
Problem ich weiß es auch nicht aber wenn
man es liest und so dann sieht man
landet man schnell über diesen drei
Stufenplan wann landet schnell bei
Versicherung der Bundesregierung na ja
wenn überhaupt dann ist das mal hier
1234 Stunden in 5000 sehen doch schlimm
genug aber nie flächendeckend und
man landet bei Erklärung wie heute wo
gesagt wird was alles getan worden ist
dass die gastspeicher voll sind und dass
man jetzt den ersten Tank erholt aber
das Gas gehört uns nicht die
gasspeicherfüllstände sagen nichts aus
weil das gehasst gehört
privatwirtschaftlichen Unternehmen und
die können das der deutschen Bevölkerung
verkaufen oder nach Frankreich oder wo
auch immerhin der Füllstand des
Gasspeichers sagt nichts aus und das hat
die Politik auch irgendwann mal
klammheimlich eingeräumt insofern ist
das auch eine Nebelkerze ja sehr sehr
viel Kerzen und so stellt man sich das
auch ein bisschen vor deswegen möchte
ich da mal konkreter werden wenn wir
hören Blackout dann reden wir auch hier
darüber dann stelle ich mir vor ich
sitze in meiner Wohnung ist es
wahnsinnig kalt und ich mache die Kerzen
an aber lassen Sie uns mal über die
Reden für die es wirklich kritisch wird
Krankenhäuser Altersheime wo sehen sie
für wen wird es besonders kritisch und
was sind die Situationen die Szenarien
die wir uns dann da vorstellen müssen
also vielleicht mal ganz kurz für die
Zuschauer was ist überhaupt der Blackout
weil die Kommunen z.B schreiben ja heute
alle sie bereiten sich auf dem Blackout
fort tatsächlich bereiten Sie sich auf
den Stromausfall vor der Unterschied ist
beim Stromausfall sind aufgrund
irgendwelcher techn diesen Schäden oder
Probleme ist eine Region ohne Strom
bedeutet drumherum hat aber alles Strom
und beim Blackout ist es halt so dass
sich die Kraftwerke aufgrund von
Mechanismen vom Stromnetz trennen und
das bedeutet großflächig ist kein Strom
mehr im Netz und das führt zu großen
Schäden und dauert dann auch lange dass
wieder herzustellen das heißt nach einem
Blackout ist es auch nicht so wenn der
Strom wieder da wäre das sofort alles
wieder läuft das ist beim Stromausfall
so und jetzt konkret auf Ihre Frage die
Hälfte aller Krankenhäuser wird wenige
Tage nur betrieben werden können die
haben zwar Notstromgeneratoren aber die
haben nicht genügend Treibstoff und vor
allen Dingen die können nur Notstrom
bereitstellen das heißt keine
ersatzstromversorgung um den
Krankenhausbetrieb aufzus aufrecht zu
erhalten dann fehlt es auch sofort an
Medikamenten die Altenheime haben zum
Großteil gar nicht vorgesorgt
Pflegedienste haben nicht vorgesagt das
heißt das sind überall man kann sagen
das medizinische System bricht zusammen
und gerade diese Leute
Altenheime Pflegebedürftige
sind die ersten die sterben werden auch
neugeborenenstationen übrigens also mir
macht das tatsächlich einfach Sorgen
weil denn gerade diese also Leute die im
Krankenhaus sind oder eben auch gerade
Wöchnerinnen Stationen alle die auf
Entbindungsstationen sind Frühchen in
den Brutkästen all das ist wirklich
gefährdet und mich mich regt das langsam
wirklich auf dass das eben eben um zu
vermeiden dass die Leute sich Sorgen
machen wird quasi nicht darüber geredet
was man vielleicht tun sollte oder wie
man sich darauf vorbereitet ich kenne
eine ganze Menge Leute die bereiten sich
tatsächlich darauf vor das heißt also
ich nehme wahr dass viele in der
Bevölkerung klüger sind als ihre
Regierung sie rechnen damit und sie sagt
und sie fangen an sich darauf
vorzubereiten
dass ich Lebensmittel dass ich Wasser
z.B dass ich weiß wie ich meine
elektrisches Garagentor aufbekomme auch
ohne Strom ja dass man dass man immer
voll getankt ist dass man den Gasgrill
sozusagen im Zweifel dass man zwei
Gasflaschen hat um in irgendeiner Form
ich habe Kinder zu versorgen ja das sind
einfach so dass man Bargeld im Haus hat
all diese Dinge tue ich einfach um um
halbwegs darauf vorbereitet zu sein das
möglich weil dann möglicherweise
vielleicht für ein paar Tage man sich
selber versorgen muss dass man das ist
kalt wird dass es kein Trinkwasser mehr
gibt das ist ja vielen allein das ist
vielen nicht klar dass wenn der Strom
ausfällt innerhalb kürzester Zeit kein
Trinkwasser mehr da ist weil wenn keine
elektrische Pumpe mehr wasserpumpt dann
gibt es halt auch kein Wasser und da
werden haufenweise Leute zu Hause sitzen
und überlegen ob sie noch irgendwie
einen Kasten Sprudel irgendwo stehen
haben es sind ganz banale Dinge und
unsere Regierung bereitet die Leute
überhaupt nicht darauf vor weil man
Angst hat wahrscheinlich dass das Panik
auslösen würde wenn die Regierung
darüber anfängt zu reden nach dem Motto
bereiten Sie sich bitte vor dann ahnt ja
jeder dass er vielleicht doch vielleicht
ein Problem sein sollte und stattdessen
kriegen wir jetzt jeden Tag das Mantra
der gaspeicher ist voll ich muss sagen
mir wird schon auch ganz anders wenn ich
mir dieses Szenario konkrete vorstelle
Historiker bestimmt ein durch seinen
Blick auf die Welt macht ihn das
trotzdem Angst wenn wir jetzt darüber
sprechen für wie wahrscheinlich halten
sie das Szenario bereiten sie sich
irgendwie vor auf seine Situation also
ich halte das Szenarium für nicht
unwahrscheinlich aus dem Grund weil da
muss man nicht Historiker sein man muss
nur mit der Bahn fahren um zu sehen wie
wir jahrelang und das ist eben nicht das
Problem dass wir jetzt nur aktuell durch
verschärft durch den ukraine-krieg haben
sondern wir leben schon seit Jahren
vielleicht sogar seit Jahrzehnten von
der Substanz wir haben wenig an die
Substanz hinein
getan deswegen haben wir so viele
Zugausfälle und und und und und und und
und also wir da ist ein grundsätzliches
Problem das ist das ein und das andere
ist ich glaube gar nicht dass die
Politik nichts macht sie macht nur das
falsche das ist das Problem und ähm denn
wir müssten eine ganz andere
Energiepolitik machen und wenn wir diese
falsche Energiepolitik weiter verfolgen
werden dann werden diese Dinge auch real
werden können und deswegen ist es eine
Grundsatzfrage und vielleicht will
deswegen auch die Regierung darüber
nicht sprechen weil wir über die
Energiefrage sprechen müssen sie haben
das angedeutet was es bedeutet LNG nach
Deutschland zu bekommen wir fragen uns
wie das eigentlich funktionieren soll
mit den vielen Windrädern man weiß doch
dass um bildlich zu sagen hinter jedem
Windrad ein ganzkraftwerk steht
und was auf den Weg gebracht und da
stellt sich jetzt habe ich hin heute
was heute sprechen
sagt wir haben einiges auf den Weg
gebracht wir haben die Verordnung auf
den Weg gebaut oder habe die übernehmen
wir gleich sprechen hat gesagt er macht
den Weg gebracht wo die Leitung legen
werden die Windparks möglich gemacht die
ist auch von der Küste wegen wird sie
schütteln mit dem Kopf wir haben den
ersten Energie
Anlegehafen bald in Wilhelmshaven äh
entlässt ja aber in einer minimal
das ist ja auch so eine Sache der macht
man mal was in größter Not schon kommen
irgendwelche Umweltverbände die Sagen um
Gottes Willen der wird Chlor ins Meer
geleitet dass wir sagen da kommt LG Gas
das uns hilft durch den nächsten Winter
zu kommen möglicherweise oder da
passiert etwas was uns hilft diese
Energie Knappheit drin also niemand
macht man es recht egal wie man es macht
immer gibt es eine der von links und
rechts kritisiert das wird natürlich
auch zu Debattenkultur die das zerstört
was gerade in einer sehr schwierigen
Phase aufgebaut wird ja aber ich
diskutiere ja weder von links noch von
rechts sondern aus der Mitte
herausgeben nein um um ich wollte und
ich war es geht nämlich nicht um das
Gemeckere oder das gemosere ob jetzt
diese Kleinigkeit oder diese Kleinigkeit
nicht stimmt sondern es geht um eine
ganz grundsätzliche Frage wie stellen
wir uns die Energiesicherheit dieses
Landes vor worauf beziehen wir Sie und
jeder weiß dass das mit erneuerbaren
Energien nicht klappen wird und jetzt
sind sie ja auch schon mittendrin in
ihrem Thema ich wollte eigentlich wollte
eigentlich schon auch einmal ganz kurz
Ding hat das Hofen Fall den Blackout mir
einmal noch kurz vor Augen führen weil
ich möchte da noch mal ganz real auch
dran bleiben muss man sicherer auf dem
Land oder in der Stadt auf dem Land
definitiv weil sie müssen sich
vorstellen was passiert hier in so einer
Stadt in einem Mehrfamilienhaus also in
so einem Hochhaus der Strom fällt aus
und für den Normalbürger ist es ein
Stromausfall weil er hat sich ja mit dem
Blackout nicht befasst das bedeutet er
macht alles wie es immer macht und das
da ist er benutzt weiter die Toilette
und er wird die Toilette mit Trinkwasser
spülen weil aus der Wasserleitung kommt
ja nichts mehr das bedeutet am Ende des
ersten Tages werden die meisten
Haushalte kein Trinkwasser mehr haben
und jetzt stellen Sie sich in so einem
Haus mit 100 Parteien vor wie die
Stimmung kippt wenn die Leute kein
Trinkwasser mehr haben und am zweiten
Tag die kleinen Kinder anfangen zu
schreien vor Durst dann sind diese
Eltern zu vielen Dingen bereit um
Trinkwasser zu bekommen dann wäre die
Supermärkte geplündert weil die
Supermärkte sind ja auch alle nicht
vorbereitet und weil auch die Politik ja
nicht vorbereitet ist ist sie nicht in
der Lage schnell zu reagieren und
Trinkwasserbrunnen bereitzustellen die
Verteilung zu machen Lebensmittel haben
die Kommunen sowieso nicht gekauft und
dann haben wir hier Bürgerkrieg
das macht gute Laune
aber jetzt muss ich noch einmal abfragen
die Wahrscheinlichkeit sie haben gesagt
zumindest das Szenario dass sie jetzt
auf Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen
Blackout ist gering aber weil die Gefahr
so groß ist und weil war es weil Risiko
wird definiert als groß als Gefahr mal
Wahrscheinlichkeit und die Gefahr
Blackout ist sehr groß das heißt das
Risiko für uns Menschen ist sehr groß
und deswegen müssen wir uns auf dem
Blackout vorbereiten das ist nichts
anderes als nur zusätzliche Versicherung
wieder Feuerversicherung eine
Unfallversicherung eine
Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung die
machen wir ja auch alle in der Hoffnung
dass wir sie nie brauchen und jetzt
kommt halt die Vorsorge dazu die
sicheren Zeiten sind vorbei und ich muss
das auch noch mal betonen wir haben
jetzt Jahre mit Energie Knappheit vor
uns weil der Kraftwerk ist
runtergefahren da ist nichts mehr und
wir haben nicht dass die Politik viel
tut weil das die Gaskrise gab es seit
dem ein seit dem September 21 und man
hat im Dezember 21 3 Kernkraftwerke
abgeschaltet ohne Not und man hat jetzt
geplant Mitte April die letzten drei
abzuschalten obwohl wir wissen dass wir
die nächsten Jahre eine Energiekrise
haben also tut die Politik nicht das was
nötig ist sondern das was die grüne
Wählerschaft unbedingt haben will